what's going on guys this is rob and
i have an idea right i have this i have
this theory i might be retreading water
here i don't know i don't usually pay
attention to other people's theories i
just kind of sit in my own little world
and do my own thing
but um there is this there's this idea
that i've been wrestling with right this
whole thing that i've been i've been
wrestling with because one of the big
things to contend with and a lot of you
all were right in the comments section
when you said that with a lot of the
stuff that goes on with the multiverse
it's very easy to confuse the audience
and even loki to a degree will do that i
know that the intention of feige and all
those guys is to say well the shows
exist by themselves and you don't need
to know what goes on in the shows in
order to understand what goes on in the
movies i don't think that's going to be
the case to be honest with you guys i
think that's what they're hoping i don't
think that's going to be the reality i
think the reality is that people are
going to be like i don't understand
what's going on and they're going to
have to watch loki to really grasp it
either that or they phrase things in
such a way to where you don't have to
have seen loki but it helps right i mean
i trust them
they haven't really done us wrong over
the last 10 years so you know i kind of
i trust them on that right let them do
their thing but um here's the thing that
i've been wrestling with right i've been
wrestling with the idea of the
multiverse now up to this point what
we've really talked about here is just
the creation of an alternate reality
which is predicated on an existing
reality so as we did in a previous video
let's use timeline a and timeline b
timeline a is the marvel cinematic
universe as we know it everything we've
seen in the movies and the tv shows and
that's it now let's say timeline b is a
reality where
wanda becomes the sorcerer supreme and
steven strange becomes the scarlet
sorcerer i guess is what we would call
them their roles are essentially
reversed right let's say that's what
happens uh that as far as our
explanation and really the seemingly the
simplest way of explaining the
multiverse that we all just kind of
based it on the idea that like that
timeline b of doctor strange being the
scarlet sorcerer and wanda being the
sorcerer supreme that the history is
exactly the same as it is in the marvel
cinematic universe except it was wanda
who was wherever she happened to be and
then traveled to meet the ancient one
and stephen strange wherever he happened
to be and the prophecy about the scarlet
sorcerer was about him and that was it
right that literally everything else in
terms of the history is the exact same
but one of the things that's gone on
really in the aftermath of loki what
i've been reading a lot about especially
when it came to kate herron as the the
the creator or director and the
screenwriter you know that guy doing an
interview and all that kind of stuff is
they were talking about the nature of
the multiverse and this is something
that i couldn't necessarily
avoid right
what they said here is unlike how we had
previously assumed that in in the the
multiversal war between all the
different variants of king that he who
remains nathaniel richards immortus
whatever you want to call him that he
had basically captured and weaponized
alioth right like literally that just
giant cloud monster and used it to
basically destroy every alternate
reality that basically did not lead to
his creation if it was an alternate
universe that led to any version of kang
that alternate reality was destroyed and
all that was left was the sacred
timeline which we referred to as the
multiverse and we'd had different
discussions on whether or not the
ancient one knew about it and different
things along those lines but the reality
here is that's the the premise we've
been operating under there was an
interview that they had done that i
wasn't really even aware of uh after the
events of loki where they were like no
so the way this works is that the the
sacred timeline was isolated from the
rest of the multiverse the rest of the
multiverse still existed out there there
were still all those different variants
of king so in effect there was no way to
actually kill kane the conqueror
that all this really meant is that he
who remains had actually used ali author
or what have you to essentially isolate
the the sacred timeline right all those
different alternate realities that lead
to the creation of he who remains that
he had essentially captured them all and
then put them all basically in a basket
right kept them isolated from the rest
of the multiverse and that was it at the
end of the loki tv show when he who
remains was killed this process of
isolation was gone and the multiverse
began to basically branch out and what
the sacred timeline did as it was
branching out is it actually merged back
with the rest of the multiverse so the
the multiverse as we would traditionally
know it all these different alternate
reality versions of kang which may or
may not be alive we can assume kang
prime uh the main bad guy from like
quantum mania that he's like the one who
came out on top where we saw like the
statues and stuff at the end of loki
that replaced the timekeepers and so on
we can call him kane prime and call it a
day right i feel like that's a cool name
kang prime it just sounds awesome uh
that he was still out there he just
wasn't able to access the sacred
timeline for whatever reason and that
was basically it and i think this is uh
this is a cool concept because as i was
thinking about that i was like well hell
this changes everything when it comes to
wanda
right because like in that moment when
wanda hears the voices of her kids at
the end of wanda vision
that could just be an instance whereby
the sacred timeline had merged out into
the rest of the multiverse and it
happened to reach an alternate reality
where wanda's kids were still there
right whether they were created by her
or not is something that we don't fully
know one of the things that we've talked
about recently is we talked about this
idea that the nature of wanda her
becoming the scarlet witch is a
universal constant she's the marvel
cinematic universe equivalent of the
molecule man oh and rhys her history is
the exact same in every single universe
across the multiverse we can possibly
even extend that to stephen strange
right then in every universe across the
multiverse steven strange always becomes
doctor strange that it's always the case
now whether or not he becomes evil is
something that we don't necessarily know
i mean we know from the what if episode
that he was driven by his desire to save
christine palmer which drove him to
basically start making deals packs
absorbing the power of just different
demonic beings that were out there so on
and so forth and seemingly what would
really be interesting is if those
what-if stories that took place were not
a result of the multiverse quote unquote
coming back in loki but we were actually
getting stories about characters who
existed out there in the multiverse they
had just been isolated all this time and
that's why we'd never seen them before
uh but regardless the thing about this
is it it brings in a sharp relief the
nature of wanda because what's recently
been discussed by
sam raimi and those guys in doctor
strange too is there like no no those
different versions of wanda that you see
those are variants those are alternate
reality versions of wanda which is cool
to see somebody finally confirm that
right so that throws our video about
them basically being the same one that
just throws it out the window right
that's gone uh but it really is
alternate versions of wanda now the
question to be asked here is just going
on this bit of information
why is this important and why does this
matter more specifically what does
america chavez have to do with any of
this stuff now here's the thing right
here's a really really cool concept in
marvel comics a really cool idea again
the mcu plays by its own rules but we're
gonna borrow more comics here for a
minute so when jonathan hickman's
avengers new god john i think was
avengers news god i love that story and
jonathan hickman's avengers and new
avengers the idea is you had something
called the incursions and we've talked
about this before so if you've heard
about this skip forward about a you know
maybe two or three minutes and and you
know you'll kind of get to you'll get
past all this but those are guys who
haven't you had the incursions basically
alternate realities crashing into each
other at the beginning of the story we
didn't know how that happened what we
ended up learning is that when dr doom
and the molecule man owen reese from the
maine marvel universe realized that
every molecule man across the multiverse
had the exact same history because they
were designed to be a bomb by the
beyonder so the beyonders could blow up
all the molecule men at the same time
and blow up all the universes at the
same time the the stance of dr doom and
the main molecule man was we have to
start killing off these different
molecule men because what it'll do is
it's basically like deactivating the
bombs of the beyonders the problem is
when they killed their first molecule
man it blew up the entire universe and
when that happened it sent the universe
is next to it bumping into each other
and that's how the incursion started and
so in order to basically try to
stabilize the multiverse without them
really knowing that they had actually
caused the incursions in the first place
they started going through and killing
all these different molecule men but
over time they began to realize their
efforts were just too slow it was like
having
three days on the clock before these
bombs go off and there's 100 bombs
spread across the city and one and a
half days in you've deactivated two and
so it's just kind of like okay there's
no way we're going to be able to take
care of all this in time and so what dr
doom did is he actually created a group
called the black swans and the black
swans basically did what he couldn't do
their actions in traveling across the
multiverse killing molecule men and even
blowing up worlds to stabilize the
incursions it was the equivalent of
doctor doom assigning the task of going
throughout the city and basically
deactivating all these bombs uh
ultimately none of it worked and the
collapse of the multiverse was
inevitable there was no way to stop it
and ultimately everything happened but
the point that i'm making here is that
if we go on the interview of the
screenwriter for loki where he talked
about the whole idea of the show and he
essentially said that traveling the
multiverse is the same as time travel
right you can't travel through time
without traveling through space and that
everything basically happens pretty much
the exact same in that instance he was
talking about the interview that he was
having and he was saying in this
universe it's happening right now and in
alternate reality was 10 seconds ago in
a different reality it's 10 seconds from
now but by and large it's all
essentially the exact same uh but the
thing about this is that if we were to
take that concept and we apply it to
wanda then again this really seems to
reinforce the theory that we had that
wanda is a multiversal constant in every
single universe wanda always becomes the
scarlet witch in every single universe
dr strange or steven strange always
becomes the you know becomes doctor
strange right whether or not he's the
source or supreme kind of changes you
know i don't really know uh again we
don't necessarily know a whole lot about
like defender wong there's still some
some little pieces here to that we need
to kind of put together but more so than
that this also goes to a lot of the
scenes that we've seen because one of
the things that's come out recently from
sam raimi and them and thank god they're
talking about it is they basically say
that like these alternate reality
versions of wanda that we see they're
variants they're not like different
versions of the same wanda from the same
universe she's not going into the past
and seeing herself or anything like that
they're just alternate reality versions
of her now that really begs the question
how is she able to travel the multiverse
without having someone like america
chavez to do it for her and i think
that's basically the way in which
they're demonstrating just how far ahead
wanda is from steven strange that
stephen strange cannot actually travel
the multiverse without the help of
america chavez hence the scene from the
trailer when like he's holding on to her
and they're falling through these
alternate realities and he's just
looking all blocky and then just just
having different appearances fingers
crossed we get like we get an instance
where he passes through the like into
the spider verse reality that would be
cool even this is like a momentary thing
he just falls through it right and like
animated miles like who are you and
stephen strange in america like don't
worry about us unless they just leave
and that's it it'd be cool if we got
that
but nonetheless back on track um they
are essentially universal constants or
multiversal constants are always the
same and showing wanda having the
ability to travel the multiverse of her
own free will of her own volition
without the help of
of anybody else stephen strange or
america chavez would show how far ahead
of him she really is but the other part
of this and this is what i think is
really really going to be a big player
in this movie i'm not entirely sure but
the other part of this is the idea of
the book of the vashanti so for those of
you guys who don't know about that and
i'm totally speculating here nothing's
been confirmed to say this is the case
but we saw a book in one of the more
recent doctor strange two trailers uh
that was just kind of sitting in like
this citadel right that looked like it
was just kind of out there in an area
that had long long since looked like it
had been destroyed but the book was just
there now the book of the vishanti
especially in the context of this movie
would be hugely important again the mcu
plays by its own rules but looking at
marvel comics for a second the dark hold
is the antithesis of black magic right
if it is a dark and evil spell it exists
in in within the pages of the dark hole
because that's literally what cathode
did cathode grabbed every single evil
spell he knew as one of the earliest
practitioners of magic who grabbed all
the evil spells all the black magic
spells he could think of threw them in
the in the dark hole and then basically
left it on earth so that he would
essentially have a way back if he was
able to find a viable vessel for his
essence or at least somebody who was
stupid enough to open up a portal
to the flickering realms and bring him
through which would basically lead to
the end of everything right just lead to
the destruction of everything on the
other side of this equation the book of
the vashanti is the antithesis of good
magic and so in a lot of ways they're
kind of at odds now in truth it's not a
one-to-one comparison because the power
of the darkhold exceeds the power of the
book of the vishanti and there are huge
differences right they're very similar
to like the jedi and the sith in the
sense that like the dark hole the magic
in that is designed for offense whereas
the magic in the book of the vashanti is
designed for defense you can use them
interchangeably right you can use book
of ashanti spells for offense and vice
versa with the dark hole but nonetheless
it's one of those things where they are
basically opposites that are designed to
kind of balance and counteract each
other and so i think that's going to
play a significant role here but again
the other thing that i really want to
talk about here for a second um is i
wanted to sort of bring back this
discussion that we had when we were
talking about like the dreams that these
people were having right that if you
look at wanda in this scenario where she
basically looks upon her younger self or
that alternate version of herself where
she's basically crying and like her kids
are there that is one of those things
where it's like she's just literally
going from university universe trying to
find out where her kids are and
ultimately i don't think she ever finds
them i don't think she ever finds a
reality where like her kids survive
maybe she does who knows right where her
kids actually exist uh as opposed to
them just being you know figments of her
creation that every alternate reality
she goes to her kids exist only because
of what was basically the events of
wanda vision so her creating a reality
within west view basically fabricating
or just creating her kids out of nothing
and like that's basically it uh that's
all she ever finds who knows right i
have no clue if that's the case but
beyond that the idea of doctor strange's
dreams that we talked about how when he
has these sort of these dream visions
that it's got a kind of blue hue to it
and i still stick by the idea that evil
version of doctor strange i still stick
by the idea that that could very well be
nightmare i don't know if that's true or
not it would make sense because if he's
having a dream
why would he communicate with an
alternate reality version of himself
through his dream unless he's
experiencing it through astral
projection but it would make more sense
if the sacred timeline basically
re-emerges with the rest of the
multiverse and in the rest of the
multiverse are all the villains we've
been waiting to see mephisto nightmare
shumogorath all those guys and now that
the sacred timeline which includes the
marvel cinematic universe has merged
with the rest of the multiverse that's
out there now they have a way in and so
that's literally like literally when
that merger happens when that murder
takes place that's when nightmare is
just like what's this
what's this alternate reality out here
right and then basically ends up
encountering steven strange and going
from there i mean from there you just
break out into a whole host of different
questions why this version of steven
strange you know i don't know for the
sake of the movie who knows right it's
just the nature of things but i don't
know i mean i do love i love this theory
crafting and this movie looks like it's
going to be amazing so let me know what
you guys think down in the comments
section about these different little
theories because this is really more of
like a hodgepodge of a bunch of
different theories that we've had as
opposed to anything in particular but
let me know what you guys think right
because i think there's some
really cool stuff here but we're gonna
bring this to an end and i will catch
you all later
peace